today we're going to try and explain
asmr what it is
how it works and why millions of people
are watching asmr videos
yeah i don't get the whole dungeon thing
at all dungeon what do you think who
could be comfortable in all that leather
no no no you're thinking of you're
thinking of something different uh uh
asmr it causes people to feel the
tingling sensations all over their body
i think we're talking about the same
videos we're not these are the ones
where they pick a safe wood right
no peanut brittle we don't need this i
guess that's two words right
asmr has nothing to do with platypus
[Music]
welcome to the y files where high iq
folks like us
come to laugh and learn today we're
talking about asmr
or autonomous sensory meridian response
which is a pleasurable
tingling feeling that some people
experience when exposed to certain
stimuli
the sensation is described as starting
at the top of the head and then running
all the way down the spine and some
people will feel it
in their extremities fingers toes limbs
those are extremities no idea what i'm
talking about
that's okay most people don't asmr is
pretty new but there's an active and
rapidly growing community online of
asmr enthusiasts what makes asmr such an
interesting phenomenon is that not
everyone experiences it and the people
that do
they have different triggers common
triggers are whispering
finger tapping clicking hair brushing
some people if you crumple a piece of
paper right up against their ear
they'll have what asmr folks call a
braingasm
no every time someone hits the like
button i feel a tingling in my dorsal
fin
whoa oh boy someone just did it i felt
that too no
baby okay ease up on the
like button we don't want pecklefish to
stroke out
so what's actually happening to the
brain and body during an
asmr experience the science is still
pretty thin but research is underway
in 2018 the university of sheffield
exposed 112 people to asmr videos
about half the people experienced the
response the other half
got nothing so what's going on here well
some studies say that asmr
could be linked to misophonia which is
where hearing a sound could elicit
a negative emotional and physiological
response
automatically think of nails on a
chalkboard which for some people
is intolerable intolerable intolerable
why is that word in every script
misophonia like asmr
could be a type of synesthesia which is
where experiencing one sense
causes an involuntary reaction in a
completely different sense so people
with severe synesthesia say they can
hear colors or taste sounds with
misophonia and asmr
hearing a certain sound is triggering a
feeling
and just like asmr people have different
misophonic triggers
for example nails on a chalkboard
doesn't bother me at all
but nails on cardboard or cardboard
rubbing together
i i can't even think about it without
getting chills it's definitely
the most awful sound ever born other
common misophonic triggers are chewing
noises
lip smacking tongue clicking
joint cracking and those bother me too
like if i'm at a restaurant and someone
is slurping their soup
it's all i can do to not walk over there
and punch them right in the face
i fantasize about it yeah let me ask you
something is it hard being so neurotic
oh it ain't easy but just like some
people find pain pleasurable platypus
sounds that are painful for some are
actually pleasurable asmr triggers for
others
there are hundreds of youtube videos of
people chewing and slurping and eating
right in your ear now i can't stand it
but
that may be an asmr trigger for you so i
will link to some of those videos below
and you can check it out
there's also a visual element to asmr
there are videos on youtube showing
people doing nothing but cutting bars of
soap into little squares
or shaving bars of soap into these thin
curls and then crushing them into tiny
little bits
this type of asmr has been called visual
white noise and some people find it
really relaxing
[Music]
other visual asmr videos show people
squishing their hands in buckets of
slime
we're pouring the colorful slime from
one container to the other
these videos have millions of views so
they're working for somebody
but what happens when we combine visual
triggers with auditory triggers
we get the greek god of asmr bob
ross dr craig richard a professor at
shenandoah university wrote a book
called brain tingles which is kind of an
asmr user's guide
dr richard recalls experiencing asmr as
a child while watching
bob ross paint he said bob would turn
his brain
into this enjoyable relaxing fuzziness
tell you what let's make a happy little
sky
i totally get that and it's no surprise
that bob ross is hugely popular in the
asmr community
he hits a ton of triggers the scraping
of the knives on the canvas
the repetitive whooshing of the
brushstrokes
bob's gentle whispering play-by-play of
the painting
the fluffy little clouds and the happy
little trees we'll build a happy little
cloud
it's really relaxing isn't it go ahead
and hit the subscribe button
go ahead and hit that button don't smash
the like button we don't like that you
gently rub the like button there you go
that's nice
and didn't bob make you feel like he was
talking directly to you
think of this tape as a private lesson
in my studio
and i reserve this front row seat just
for you this kind of intimate personal
attention is common with asmr
brain scans of people experiencing
tingles have similar scans to people
that are being
groomed or gently cared for and for
people with this trigger
it's not the touching that causes the
tingles it's the personal attention
many asmr content creators will role
play
caring grooming activities like hair
washing hair brushing
or blow drying now the sound of a blow
dryer does nothing for me
but bubble wrap oh
all day long
other creators known as asm artists will
role play doing your makeup for you just
apply that
or they'll pretend to be a teacher
giving you gentle praise and reassurance
so welcome to your first
day of class some of these triggers may
sound silly
but to people who are asmr sensitive the
experience has been proven to lower
their heart rate reduce their blood
pressure
and reduce levels of fight-or-flight
hormones in their bloodstreams
hormones like cortisol and adrenaline
these are the same benefits that people
get from meditation so
there might be something to this that
was a good one but why does asmr work
with some people
and not others well we don't know yet
every individual has unique
physiological characteristics
and there are other factors like the
culture in which they live
or the environment where they were
raised asmr is just another example
about how the human brain is
fascinating and complicated and
downright weird
and if being weird is wrong i don't want
to be right
platypus thanks for hanging out with us
today my name is aj
that's hecklefish this has been the
y-files are you asmr sensitive
do you have any specific asmr triggers
put in the comment section so we can all
get tingles
we're just getting started here at the y
file so do us a favor hit the subscribe
button
become a founding filer and help us
shape the content of the channel we put
a lot of work into these videos so if
you enjoyed them
do us a favor hit the thumbs up button
nothing helps a new channel more
than that like button tingles baby give
me those tingles
and i hope we earned your subscription
today but if we didn't i promise we'll
keep making brandy content until we do
earn it until next time be safe
be kind and know that you are
[Music]
appreciated
no you